how can well-meaning data-driven
attempts to solve social problems
actually make things worse Campbell's
law may hold the answer
crafted by a social scientist nearly a
half-century ago
the law basically says when a measure
becomes a target it ceases to be a good
measure the problems play out in many
fields including education attempts to
evaluate schools and teachers based on
reading and math scores cause educators
to do everything possible to boost
results whether that's narrowing
curricula going goofy for test
preparation or cooking the books it
brings to mind there's old Soviet
factories with the production quotas and
shoddy products but Campbell's law
applies to more than test scores we've
seen a play out when schools are told to
improve school safety numbers or the
drive up graduation rates now none of
this means that we should shy away from
accountability or measurement in
education but it does mean that we need
to be a lot more attentive to how those
metrics get used they need to respect
the law Campbell's law that is how do
you think we should tackle
accountability in American education let
us know in your comments also let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI